togliamo ahi abbiamo tolto due denti
Cosa state facendo 3 2
1 faremo
l'anestesia
Ah che schifo Chi è stato io non sono
stata assolutamente sono state loro ma
non è vero Ma no è stata lei appena
arrivata oggi nuova Challenge dottore
buono contro dottore cattivo dovrò
affrontare varie Challenge buono contro
cattivo voi cliccate subito mi piace e
oggi salutiamo Daniela che ha scritto
questo bellissimo commento Ciao Anita
Vitale mi è piaciuto tutto il video Vi
voglio bene grazie Daniela se anche voi
volete essere salutati Guardate questo
video fino alla fine e poi scrivete nei
commenti Qual è stato il vostro momento
preferito e ovviamente cliccate mi piace
ma ora iniziamo subito la Challenge
siete pronti via Io sono la dottoressa
Alice Questo non è un lavoro facile se
oggi sbaglierai Qualcosa con i pazienti
verrai subito licenziata Ah E
dimenticavo oggi avrai due
assistenti Oh che carine sono le tue
sorelline Ma cosa stai dicendo loro sono
due bravissime dottoresse Io sono
dottoressa
Io sono la dottoressa Eli E se non le
tratterai bene verrai immediatamente
licenziata Ma come dottoresse Sono solo
delle
bambine Aspettate che cosa Che cosa
state facendo Io non sono paziente Io
sono per lavorare con voi non devo
essere visitata aiuto io adesso sono
impegnata quindi devo andare Beh buona
fortuna
aiuto Basta eri dobbiamo lavorare
assieme
adesso lavorare con noi noi non abbiamo
bisogno di nessun aiuto infatti Noi
siamo delle dottoresse bravissime non
abbiamo bisogno del tuo aiuto ma che
cosa state
[Musica]
dicendo Qualcuno ha suonato alla porta
un
paziente
[Musica]
Buongiorno qual è il
problema mettiamo noi a corag adesso
siediti
Siediti Allora ci penso io Buongiorno e
un paziente E allora qual è il problema
Che cosa le è
successo Non ho capito niente
ehm vado subito a controllare nel libro
di medicina per capire quale può essere
il problema forse ha un problema alla
lingua vado subito a
controllare Ok adesso Dimmi il tuo
nome Perfetto data di
[Musica]
nascita ci pensiamo noi a
curarti Sì noi siamo
[Musica]
bravissime
No questo non
funziona Proviamo con
questo mi ho fatto malissimo Ehi aspetta
riesco a parlare Grazie grazie
dottoresse Grazie sì Adesso dimmi qual è
il tuo problema e Ecco allora io
stamattina mi sono svegliato e non
riuscivo a parlare V la lingua
gonfissima mi fa malissimo Allora adesso
ti visito io sì sì Sì Ah Passami le
pinzette Ecco le pinzette le pinzette
perché Ciao sono l'emoji di Anita è
uscito il mio nuovo libro La città
stregata con un nuovissimo mistero da
risolvere insieme a Vitale in più dentro
c'è l'alfabeto segreto con cui
comunicheremo tanti messaggi segreti
assieme per i primi ordini Riceverete
anche il poster autografato quindi
prendetelo subito trovate il link in
descrizione oppure la trovate in
libreria devo cercare subito
informazioni sul problema di quel
paziente praticamente non riusciva a
parlare quindi devo vedere qual è il suo
problema per riuscire a risolverlo il
prima possibile per non essere
licenziata Spero che nel frattempo le
due piccole dottoresse non stiano
combinando un disastro meglio che mi
sbrigo
Ah le pinzette non
funziona Tu tienilo fermo Ok vado
[Musica]
[Applauso]
almeno non sentirà più dolore già Che
brave dottoresse che
siamo che cosa è successo che cosa avete
fatto a quel paziente l'ho visto
scappare via e non riusciva più a
parlare che cosa G avete fatto eh
Abbiamo curato il paziente e gli faceva
male la lingua e gel l'abbiamo
tolta Che cosa che cosa avete fatto alla
sua lingua Oh no che cosa faccio adesso
il capo non lo deve scoprire Anica
perché il paziente è uscito via
scappando e urlando No no no non sono
stata io sono state
loro come ti permetti ad incolpare loro
Loro sono bravissime delle sperte se
succede nuovamente qualcosa del genere
sarai
licenziata devo stare super attenta la k
si è arrabbiata tantissimo Non devo
rischiare di essere licenziata questa
volta il paziente lo curerò io e starò
super attenta un altro cliente Prego
prego Buongiorno Sto male ho la febbre
per favore aiutatemi Non mi sento bene
Prego Prego si accomodi e si sieda pure
ha la febbre adesso ci pensiamo noi a
curarlo non c'è problema Sei in buone
mani allora aspetta un momento qua che
prendo il cosino per misurare la febbre
il termometro insomma E aspetta un
momento che arrivo subito Spero che
questa dottoressa sia brava Mi sento
troppo male ho la febbre Aiutatemi
Allora eccomi qua misuriamo subito la
febbre 39 e mezzo 39 e mezo c'avevo 39
prima mi sta salendo velocemente
Aiutatemi Non ti preoccupare non ti
preoccupare Ora ci pensiamo noi a
curarti Devo solo capire quali sono le
medicine giuste vado subito a
controllare Arrivo subito eh Un dottore
che non sa quali sono le medicine giuste
questo mi fa molta paura Speriamo bene
quali saranno le medicine Gi Forse
questa o questa oppure questa mi sa che
devo tornare a controllare nel libro di
medicina quale devo
prendere questo no questo serve per
un'altra cosa
controlliamo signore non si preoccupi no
no non c'è nessun problema adesso Lo
curiamo subito deve soltanto chiudere
gli occhi chiudere gli occhi
ok
[Musica]
sento qualcosa di fresco è molto
piacevole questa sensazione
[Musica]
fresca Ma che cosa state facendo Sto
ancora molto
male Troppo
divertente li abbiamo disegnato un
gabinetto con la puzza della cacca con
delle mosche che li girano
sopra perché stanno ridendo non ne
avranno combinato una delle loro spero
andiamo a
controllare oh no oh no che cosa hanno
fatto eh come stai Tutto bene Ah sì le
le dottoresse mi hanno curato mi sento
molto meglio mi è passata la febbre
benissimo Allora puoi anche andare a
casa prima che torni il capo vai pure a
casa anzi guarda ti regalo anche una
caramella perché sei stato un ottimo
paziente Io adoro le caramelle Vai a
casa Ciao grazie grazie ciao Meno male
non ci sono specchi qua in questo centro
medico così il paziente non ha visto che
G hanno disegnato un gabinetto in faccia
quelle due pesti gli hanno fatto un
altro scherzetto dovrò stare più attenta
d'ora in poi tutt dottori non sento più
niente non sento più niente eh Qualcuno
sta parlando non sento niente Sì sì sì
sì certo ci penso io a curarti e non ti
preoccupare Accomodati pure nella sedia
ora Arrivo subito con gli attrezzi
Giusti e voi Mi raccomando non combinat
un'altra delle vostre Eh ok va bene
Eccomi eccomi Quindi tu non senti niente
che cosa Eh ho preso un dente No no No
cioè sei sordo il bordo la pizza col
bordo Sì mi piace il bordo della pizza
non ti preoccupare adesso ti curo sei un
canguro No io a casa non c'ho il canguro
c'ho il gatto non c'ho il canguro Sì
vabbè insomma vediamo un po' le
orecchie effettivamente c'è un po' di
cerume qua legume no cerume e vado
subito a prendere lo Stura
[Musica]
orecchie
che mi fa schifo C'ho qualcosa qui
[Musica]
dentro Allora lo Stura orecchie lo Stura
orecchie forse questo è uno Stura
orecchie no non mi sembra uno Stura
orecchie Forse questa è un Stura
orecchie no non è neanche questa devo
sbrigarmi
quale sarà lo Stura orecchie questo no
non mi sembra uno Stura orecchie Uffa
Qual è Rosta orecchie Allora signor
paziente Qual è il suo problema che cosa
qual è il suo problema no non sento cosa
qual è il suo nome come Qual è il suo
nome ma qualcuno sta parlando non sento
niente Qual è la tua data di
nascita cosa forse ha un problema alle
orecchie no striamo le
orecchie
aiuto questa medicina Ahia Ma che
medicina Eh ma che cura è ahia è
nuova adesso ci senti
i serpenti dove sto i serpenti mi fanno
schifo tu distra Ilo Sì sì sì lo
distraggo
io che Cos'è questo Cos'è
[Musica]
questo no che non ci voglio andare a
scuola dove siamo dove sono eccomi
eccomi era un momento in magazzino per
prendere questo attrezzo per le
orecchie Cosa ci fate voi Qua non avete
combinato uno dei vostri scherzetti
Spero no no vediamo subito l'altro
orecchio
Ah che schifo c'era questo nel tuo
orecchio Ah che schifo cos'è
sento e aspetta sento
benissimo grazie grazie dottore grazie
dottore che
schifo Grazie dottore mi avete curato
lascerò una recensione da 5 Stelle siete
i più forti di tutti grazie Ancora
grazie ciao ciao
grazie stavo guardando il telefono e un
paziente ha lasciato cinque stelle
bravissima Anita hai superato il lavoro
Non ci posso credere nonostante tutte le
cose che sono successe e ce l'ho fatta
Grazie Ora mi aspetta subito il prossimo
lavoro 3 2
1 Quale sarà il mio secondo
lavoro dove sono Ciao io sono Jessica la
proprietaria del salone di bellezza
sappi che dovrai lavorare molto sodo
perché questo è il salone di bellezza
migliore di tutta Italia salone di
bellezza Oh no Questo vuol dire che devo
fare l'estetista Oh no io non sono brava
in queste cose ma ce la metterò tutta
perché devo ricevere le cinque stelle e
non essere licenziata per superare anche
questo lavoro mi raccomando stanno per
arrivare i primi clienti quindi deve
essere tutto
impeccabile ok Io adesso vado Mi
raccomando voglio vedere soltanto
recensioni positive Sì sì non c'è
problema Non c'è problema sono
prontissima per i primi clienti Adesso
ti faremo noi bella che cosa no che cosa
volete farmi Oh no no ma che cosa mi
stai attaccando ai
capelli non so se la Ka è
d'accordo eh che cosa avete
fattoi sei un Arc
cicato Salve buongiorno è possibile una
manicure un cliente un cliente Prego
Prego Prego si comodi Eh grazie molto
gentile Allora metti le mani qua e
arrivo subito con tutta l'attrezzatura
per manicure Ah che carina C'è anche una
bella acconciatura Io sto andando a
prendere gli attrezzi per la manicure e
torno subito mi raccomando non combinat
una delle vostre ok Sì certo faremo le
brave Speriamo che sia vero questo volta
Torno
subito pensi anche tu a quello che penso
io credo di sì gli rasiamo le
sopracciglia Ma no gli facciamo la
ceretta
Ah infatti è molto più creativo mi piace
facciamolo Gira la mano ma che cosa sta
[Musica]
succedendo lo tengo fermo ah
Cosa state facendo 3 2
Ah Mi hanno spaccato un
braccio Ti è piaciuta la
Cetta io non volevo la Cetta volevo la
manicure basta me ne vado questo centro
estetico non mi merita vado via ciao
ciao eccomi eccomi Ecco tutti gli
accessori per la manicure Dov'è finito
il
cliente non mi dire che G avete fatto un
altro dei vostri scherzetti no Ma cosa
dici il cliente è scappato via da
solo non vi credo secondo me ne avete
combinato una delle vostre invece che
cosa sta cento nel mio
salare mi è appena arrivata una
recensione negativa un cliente voleva
una semplice manicure e gli è stata
fatta la ceretta Chi è stato io non sono
stata assolutamente io sono andata a
prendere queste cose per la manicure che
aveva chiesto quindi probabilmente Anzi
Sicuramente sono state loro ma non è
vero Ma no è stata lei appena arrivata
noi la tramo qui tanto e chi lo dice che
non sei stata tu Ma no io non c'ero non
sono stata io lo giuro Sono andata a
prendere le cose per la manicure Loro
sono sembrano così brave ma in realtà
non sono brave come sembra ma se siamo
solo delle bambine che vuoi che
facciamo beh per forza sei stata tu la
nuova arrivata Guarda allora invece Che
faccino Gico Guarda che se sbagli ancora
una volta verrai licenziata è una
promessa Buongiorno Posso prendere un
appuntamento per fare le sopracciglia
Certo certo siamo liberi proprio adesso
si accomodi Pure Si vede che ha proprio
bisogno di fare le sopracciglia prego
prego Si accomodi grazie grazie grazie
Allora vediamo un po' queste
sopracciglia sì Eh qua ci vuole una
pinzetta gigante Allora prendo subito le
pinzette Le ho nascoste io le
pinzette che brava così adesso che
distratta potremo fare uno scherzo al
cliente Sì
andiamo Erano qua le pinzette non ci
sono più devo andare a controllare il
magazzino e torno subito adesso ti
faremo una cura per le ciglia però devi
chiudere gli occhi Sì per le
sopracciglia però sì per le sopracciglia
scusa ok Perché mi sono cresciute
durante la notte così tanto non lo so
Che
strano Sì però le sopracciglia sono qui
su che cosa state faccendo G stiamo
facendo una maschera al viso così sei
ancora più bello ah una maschera così
son più bello va bene se son più bello
Allora va bene Ti sta rilassando Signore
Ah sì con questa maschera di bellezza è
proprio rilassante Sì mi sto rilassando
Ma quand'è che ha iniziato a toglierle
fra un po' prima facciamo questa
maschera così sarà ancora più bello va
bene va bene Oh non le ho trovate da
nessuna parte le pinze Ma non è che le
avete
[Musica]
che cosa avete fatto a questo
cliente
Perché piacci che cosa mi avete fatto
guarda
Ah che schifo perché mi avete rovinato
così no il mio povero faccino Volevo
solo fare le
sopracciglia aspetta aspetta penso io
rimediare Ora ti strucco ma non lasciare
una recensione negativa da una stella Ok
ma non ci pensa neanche a rimanere un
altro secondo qui Ah mi avete
rovinato avete fatta Oh no spero che la
kappa non lo scoprirà Per quale motivo
il cliente è scappato via piangendo
Speriamo che non lasci una recenzione
negativa sei stata nuovamente Tu
Anita Sei
licenziata no no no no no no aspetta non
licenziarmi posso spiegarti non sono
stata io sono state loro non è vero Noi
stavamo soltanto qui ordinando pulendo
aggiungendo trucchi comprando trucchi
Secondo me sei stata tu perché noi siamo
troppo brave Noi siamo del mestiere Ti
prego dammi un'altra possibilità con il
prossimo cliente riuscirò a rimediare
vedrai avrò cinque stelle e va bene ma
sappi che questo è il salone migliore di
tutta Italia quindi ti do un'ultima
possibilità Altrimenti puoi anche
andartene via Buonasera un altro cliente
e possibile una maschera rilassante per
il viso Certo certo non c'è problema si
accomodi pure è facilissima Questa è una
maschera per il viso Prego si sieda si
sieda molto gentile aspetti un momento
qua che vado a prendere la maschera per
il viso va bene grazie Ah questa volta
non mi farò fregare dalle due pezzi
infatti Ora guardo la parola segreta nel
libro e vedo come posso fare a distrarre
Eccolo qua dal mio libro La città
stregata se ancora non ce l'avete
prendetelo subito dentro c'è l'alfabeto
segreto con cui potete tradurre tutte le
parole segrete dei miei video E ora
vediamo subito la parola segreta del
giorno T Questa è la parola segreta
questa parola mi ha fatto venire in
mente una grande idea per distrarli
andiamo subito che scherzetto possiamo
fare questa volta magari facciamo una
maschera una maschera di fango di funghi
Ah ecco qua ho preso un antistress
Questo è un naso finto con i brufoli
questo forse terrà impegnate le due
pezzi dovranno schiacciare tutti questi
brufoli Vediamo se le tiene impegnate
Ehi ragazze Guardate Ho un regalino per
voi e un naso finto con i brufoli volete
provare spiarli Sì va
bene
Eh che schifo Sembrano veramente veri Ok
mentre loro sono distratte devo
sbrigarmi Ecco qua la maschera per il
viso Wow Ecco qua la maschera per il
viso
ta Ah è
rinfrescante è anche rilassante proprio
quello che cercavo e se poi gli piace
questa maschera per il viso dopo ci può
lasciare cinque stelle come recensione
cinque stelle ci penserò e allora ti
piace Sì è molto fresca e rilassante Ah
ma mi lasci un po' di spazio anche a me
lo stai prendendo tutto Ehi Adesso lo
voglio io Ah
uff
[Musica]
Ok il tempo è scaduto andiamo a togliere
la
maschera
t t Come ti senti Ah benissimo mi sento
ringiovanito Allora lascerai C stelle
Assolutamente sì e lo consiglierò anche
ai miei amici S Sì grazie prego torna
pure quando
vuoi ce l'ho fatta ora resta che torni
la ca e veda che mi hanno lasciato
cinque stelle No vabbè sono arrivate
cinque stelle sei stata tu Anita Sì ce
l'ho fatta a superare questo lavoro e
ora devo subito correre al terzo e
ultimo lavoro 3 2 1 via dove sono Quale
sarà il mio prossimo lavoro
Buongiorno Oggi tutti i pazienti
dovranno uscire col sorriso ho capito
Sono una dentista Beh certo Cosa pensavi
di essere Ok ok Ora mi preparo subito
con tutti gli attrezzi e farò un ottimo
lavoro vedrai riceverò C stelle Mi
raccomando Altrimenti verrai licenziata
subito no non posso essere licenziata
nel mio ultimo lavoro ce la metterò
tutta Buona fortuna Ok iniziamo subito a
prendere gli attrezzi che ci servono
prima che arrivi il primo paziente che
bello fare le dentiste è bellissimo
perché puoi staccare i denti alle
persone
Oh no ancora voi Mi raccomando non
rifate uno dei vostri scherzetti adesso
perché questa è l'ultima Challenge devo
vincerla saremo brave Sì tranquilla in
questo lavoro faremo più le brave
Speriamo che sia vero questa volta lui è
il primo paziente ha un dolore al dente
fate del vostro meglio perché non lo
senta più il primo paziente Prego Prego
si accomodi ho mangiato troppe caramelle
e adesso mi fa male un dente per favore
Aiutatemi devo continuare a mangiare
tutti quei dolci ma con questa Caria non
posso non c'è problema guardiamo subito
i denti e vediamo qual è il problema
Comunque sappi che mangiare troppi dolci
fa male quindi dovresti darti una
regolata mangiare meno dolci Sì non lo
so se ci riesco e ci devi riuscire apri
la
bocca eh sì c'è una bella carie ma non
c'è problema perché possiamo curarla noi
vado subito a prendere l'attrezzo giusto
per curare le c e dopo potrò mangiare
Tanti dolcetti No Come no ma io cambio
dentista allora Ahi ahi Che dolore Che
dolore Ehi paziente ci pensiamo noi a
curarti Oh Grazie siete molto gentili
toglieremo la carie Oh bene Poi dopo
potrò mangiare i dolcetti No Come no Ma
perché nessuno mi vuol far mangiare i
dolcetti Apri grande non aver paura Ah
che bel dentone Che hai Stai fermo e
adesso te lo
[Musica]
togliamo Ah abbiamo tolto due denti sì a
noi ci piace tantissimo togliere i denti
poverino il paziente mi fa proprio pena
che bello questo lavoro Oh ma perché mi
avete tolto due denti Beh Tolto il dente
Ho tolto l'oro No infatti Beh in effetti
non mi fa più male Beh se vuoi te ne
togliamo un altro No no no no io adesso
scappo e non tornerò mai più qui
Addio che Zetto
riuscito e ma dovè finito il paziente
non abbiamo fatto niente è scappato da
solo già m Secondo me invece avete
combinato qualcosa voi stavolta siamo
state Brave brave già per il prossimo
paziente vi terrò sott'occhio perché
quel cliente è scappato via Non lo
voglio neanche sapere Guardate Per
favore fatemi fare bella figura
soprattutto tu Anita
Ok adesso sta per entrare Il secondo
cliente Mi
raccomando prego Oh
Buongiorno eare qui qui qui e qui e
anche qui dietro qui tutti tutti denti
mi fanno male tutti i
denti Beh questo è un problemone però
sapranno sicuramente Cosa
fare per
favore tutti i denti questa sarà
difficile da sbrigare sarà difficile
curare un paziente a cui fanno male
tutti i denti ma ci riusciremo prego
prego sia comodi qua si
accomodi oh io mi fa malissimo anche se
mi siedo Ok non c'è problema Ci penso io
a curare tutti i denti però questa volta
devo stare attenta siccome l'altra volta
le due bambine cattive hanno tolto due
denti all'altro paziente questa volta
chiamerò la capa Alice e chiederò che
rimanga qua a controllare vado subito a
chiamarla adesso che Anita non c'è
possiamo togliere tutti i denti
sì e per prima cosa faremo
l'anestesia non ha funzionato Allora
provo
io
[Musica]
Beh
cos C miei
dente miei
Dent Eccoci
qua che cosa sta succedendo qua Anita
cosa hai fatto No no non posso aver
fatto niente questa volta perché ero
assieme a te hai ragione quindi siete
state voi due ma lui era già così senza
denti Esatto È un vecchietto senza
denti Madonna totale toale Ah ok Allora
nessun problema ti mettiamo una
bellissima
[Applauso]
dentiera
prepariamo il prossimo
scherzetto Guarda qui c'è un d dicio che
cosa potremo fare Magari possiamo
mettere questo acido qui dentro che farà
cadere tutti i denti al paziente Ah sì
sì speriamo che non se ne accorgano
eh Salve Buonasera vorrei denti molto
Bianchi eh Salve Certo È facilissimo lo
sbiancamento dei denti sono già pronta
Prego si sieda qua questa volta ho
deciso che non mi allontanerò così le
due pesti non potranno fare nessuno
scherzo e non verrò licenziata devo
assolutamente prendere cin stelle questo
è l'ultimo paziente Ecco fatto sistemato
Ehi assistenti dentiste Portatemi subito
il dentifricio
sbiancante grazie E ora procediamo
subito a sbiancare i denti del nostro
paziente questo sarà un gioco da ragazzi
cosa Che cosa è successo Perché è nero
questo dentifricio Che vuol dire nero il
dentifricio nero No no stavo scherzando
cioè sono bianchissimi i tuoi denti
adesso vero Sì
bianchissimi Oh no questa volta verrò
licenziata davvero Devo trovare una
soluzione prima che torni la capa Sì
bianchissimi bianchissimi bellissimi Oh
Sono proprio
soddisfatto sono venuta a vedere come
sta procedendo il lavoro forza Apra la
bocca no No non c'è bisogno che apre la
bocca sta andando benissimo lei non mi
deve dire Cosa devo fare Apra la
bocca ma ha i denti neri No non è colpa
mia lo giuro non ce lo Spata io è stato
è stato questo speci fro strano Anita
questo non deve accadere tu sei
licenziata No Questa volta sono stata
licenziata per davvero ho perso la
Challenge però sai Anita mi fa un po'
pena e per colpa nostra è stata
licenziata ho una soluzione io per
[Musica]
salvarla abbiamo salvato la situazione
sì ce l'abbiamo
[Musica]
fatta Guardate allo specchio
Grazie Wow sono bianchissimi i denti
Grazie Ora vi lascerò una recensione
positiva C stelle grazie mille ciao
ciao Ehi Aspetta ma sono arrivate cinque
stelle Questo vuol dire che sono stata
ingiusta con Anita devo assolutamente
chiamarla per dire che ha superato il
lavoro
Anita Eccomi scusami Anita hai superato
il lavoro mi sono arrivate cinque stelle
Ma com'è possibile questo Anita abbiamo
deciso di aiutarti stavolta perché ci
siamo dispiaciute Tanto per te non
volevamo che tu andassi via per sempre
quindi ti abbiamo aiutato Challenge
completata Mi raccomando scrivete nei
commenti Qual è stato il vostro momento
preferito e ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro
caselline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione
Ciao